certains les ont pris pour des fous
d'autres pour des ro des valeurs de la
gauche
durant huit mois ces militants
socialistes ont mené une grève inédite
en ne renvoyant plus leurs cotisations
rue de solférino il critiquait notamment
la loi travail demandé un changement de
politique gouvernementale et une vraie
primaire aujourd'hui il estime avoir été
longtemps on n'a pas obtenu la le
changement de la ligne économique
notamment sur la loi travail sur la
justice fiscale mais c'est dans les
primaires que cela va se régler
donc du coup nous voilà de retour à la
maison notre volonté est de reprendre
les clés de la maison socialiste
ainsi s'ils reviennent c'est pour peser
sur les choix et promouvoir les valeurs
d'arnaud montebourg
ici à frangy-en-bresse certains font
plus qui croire il s'habille même en
marine r oui ses pairs c'est notre
candidat
on va se battre pour ça les primaires et
après la présidentielle parce qu'on va
gagner les primaires mais la france
vis-à-vis de paris aura tout de même
laissé quelques séquelles dans cette
petite section de 40 militants certains
plats qu'elle c'est pas énorme mais
c'est 7 7 personnes qui n'ont pas repris
leur carte qui l'a reprendront peut-être
du fait du vote bientôt des élections
internes pour les législatives de début
décembre
donc ces personnes la sienne ne
reprennent par leurs gardes ne pourront
pas voter donc la reprendront peut-être
en attendant tous trinquet des jours
meilleurs
reste à savoir quand ils vont arriver